[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: You cannot manage
what you don't measure.
People's time is the most
expensive and valuable asset
in the company.
And this is the secret way
that GeoTab goes to market.
We work very closely
with the customers.
We understand--
SPEAKER 2: We started
thinking about,
what do we do really well.
Over the 20 years
of growth, we've
helped you all stay agile in
productivity, fleet safety,
compliance, expandability.
SPEAKER 1: Every one in five
trucks that you see on the road
today in North America has
a GeoTab device installed.
It's amazing.
SPEAKER 2: This is a very
vibrant, very healthy
ecosystem.
SPEAKER 1: We need
to think about what
is the future connect
to transportation.
SPEAKER 2: It's the
year 2020, and it's
time to launch a sixth pillar,
the sustainability pillar.
SPEAKER 1: We have to
open our customers' minds
to the art of the possible.
This is the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]